[Música]
el comité de la cámara de representantes
Que investigó los hechos relacionados
con el intento de la toma del Capitolio
en Estados Unidos recomendó en su
informe final acusar al expresidente
Donald Trump por obstrucción e
insurrección
un Jurado del estado de California
encontró culpable al ex productor de
Hollywood Harvey weinstein por cargos de
violación y agresión sexual Ahora solo
resta que la justicia californiana
dictamine Qué tipo de pena imponer
y después de varios días de encuentro
sin negociaciones la Cumbre cop 15
realizada en la ciudad de Montreal en
Canadá dejó un acuerdo histórico en
materia de biodiversidad que busca
proteger el 30% del territorio del
planeta y de los cuerpos de agua
Hola Bienvenidos a este informativo de
Franz 24 en el que hacemos énfasis en
las principales noticias del continente
americano vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos en la ciudad de Washington en
donde el comité de la cámara de
representantes Que investigó los hechos
ocurridos durante el intento de la toma
el Capitolio el 6 de enero del 2021 el
comité sugirió que el expresidente
Donald Trump sea acusado por obstrucción
e insurrección Andrés triviño nos cuenta
más
un pedido a la justicia el comité
legislativo que Investiga el asalto del
6 de enero del 2021 al Capitolio
recomienda el departamento de Justicia
estadounidense imputar el expresidente
Donald Trump por obstrucción a la
justicia incitación al terrorismo
conspiración en contra del gobierno
federal y declaraciones falsas a la
justicia
La fe es la base de la Democracia
estadounidense si se rompe la fe se
rompe nuestra democracia y Donald Trump
la rompió perdió las elecciones de 2020
y lo sabía buscaba anular los resultados
con la intervención de varias partes
para bloquear la transferencia de poder
tras un año y medio de investigaciones
la comisión considera que Trump no actúa
en solitario además de encontrar que
pasó la tarde bien del ataque por
televisión el 6 de enero de 2021 unas
10.000 personas se manifestaron en
frente del Capitolio y cerca de 800
irrumpieron en el edificio mientras se
ratificaba la victoria del demócrata Joe
biden en las elecciones presidenciales
hubo cinco muertos y unos 140 heridos
fue la primera vez que un presidente
estadounidense rechazó su deber
constitucional de transferir el poder
pacíficamente al siguiente Durante los
últimos 18 meses el comité selecto ha
reconocido nuestra obligación de hacer
todo lo posible para garantizar que esto
nunca suceda otra vez
esta fue la última audiencia del 2022 en
la cual el comité quiso difundir sus
conclusiones antes de la nueva
legislatura el 3 de enero la mayoría
republicana que abre a partir de ese día
podría disolver este órgano y el
enjuiciamiento sería detenido Después de
varias semanas de audiencias y también
de nueve días de deliberación es un
Jurado del estado de California encontró
culpable al ex productor de Hollywood
Harvey weinstein en este caso weinstein
enfrentaba dos cargos de violación y
otros cinco por agresión sexual en
hechos ocurridos entre los años 2005 y
2013 en la ciudad de Los Ángeles en
California el ex Magnate que esperaba
sentencia tras las rejas ya fue
sentenciado también a 23 años de prisión
por otro caso similar en el estado de
Nueva York ahora sólo resta que la
Justicia californiana dictamine La
Sentencia
dueño y ceo de Twitter realizó una
encuesta en la que consultó a los
usuarios para saber si continuaba al
frente de esta red social el resultado
no favoreció a mosc a la pregunta si
debo renunciar a seguir al frente de
Twitter el 57.5% votó a favor de sí
cerca del 10 de 17,5 millones de
personas votaron en esta encuesta ahora
la pregunta que queda es si mosc
continuará o no y si tendrá en cuenta
este sondeo de opinión
y seguimos en Estados Unidos en donde la
Corte Suprema bloqueó de manera temporal
una orden que ponía fin a las
restricciones relacionadas con la
pandemia de covid 19 para los
solicitantes de asilo en ese país
norteamericano el magistrado presidente
John Roberts emitió la orden justo
cuando algunos estados conservadores
intentan mantener las medidas que
limitan la solicitudes de asilo Roberts
concedió la suspensión hasta nueva orden
y le pidió al Gobierno Federal Que
responda a más tardar el día martes
horas antes de que expire el plazo para
levantar estas restricciones que por
favor se le hablan del corazón al
presidente y deje pasar a todas estas
personas que estamos por acá porque
hemos pasado mucho sufrimiento hemos
sufrido mucho desde que salimos de
Venezuela la selva Todos esos países que
hemos pasado y de verdad le pido de
corazón de que nos dé la oportunidad de
pasar nos vamos ahora hasta Perú el
gobierno de Dina bo afirmó que las
protestas en diferentes zonas del país
han comenzado ya a desescalar después de
que al menos 23 personas perdieran la
vida entre tanto la mandataria anunció
un cambio en su gabinete cambiará al
Primer Ministro mientras que la
cancillería protestó por lo que
considera injerencias de otros gobiernos
de izquierda de América Latina el
informes de lluís Muñoz
los gobiernos de izquierda de
latinoamérica mantienen la presión sobre
Perú este lunes el presidente de México
Andrés Manuel López Obrador volvió a
insistir en su oferta de asilo para el
presidente de derrocado Pedro Castillo
actualmente en prisión preventiva
mientras la cancillería peruana envió
una carta a su contraparte colombiana el
presidente Gustavo Petro ha estado
cuestionando en sus redes el
encarcelamiento de Castillo las
afirmaciones del presidente Petro
constituyen una injerencia inaceptable
en los asuntos internos del Perú
especialmente grave en el contexto de
actos de violencia que han ocasionado
lamentables pérdidas de Vidas humanas
una semana después de nombrar gabinete
la nueva presidente Dina boluarte dijo
que iba a reformarlo Cambiando al Primer
Ministro Pedro Angulo y asegura que las
protestas están cediendo pero las
imágenes todavía lo desmienten en la
frontera entre Bolivia y Perú hay más de
mil camiones varados estamos esperando
desde el día martes en la noche
cosa que no nos dan paso ya mirar son
cuántos días y ya se nos acaba la
economía los manifestantes han cerrado
el puente internacional que conecta
ambos países
emprendiendo la lucha apoyando a
nuestros hermanos de Lima por tantas
muertes que hubo por el problema que
tenemos por el mismo hecho por haberle
bajaba Castillo la institución de Pedro
Castillo el 7 de diciembre ha desatado
la ira por todo el país en unas
protestas que ya dejan más de 20 muertos
a continuación otras noticias destacadas
en la región aquí en France 24
la guerrilla colombiana del eln anunció
una tregua para navidad y para fin de
año por lo que pone fin a un paro armado
indefinido que estaba instaurado en
diferentes regiones del departamento de
chocó en donde tenían confinados acerca
de 10.000 de sus habitantes
cerca de 4.8 millones de paraguayos
estaban llamados a participar en las
primarias presidenciales del pasado
Domingo Santiago Peña fue elegido como
candidato por el partido Colorado
Mientras que el liberal Efraín alegre
será el candidato a la presidencia por
la llamada concertación nacional
y el presidente de Ecuador Guillermo
lasso sostuvo un encuentro oficial en la
casa blanca con el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden los mandatarios
hablaron de temas de cooperación en
seguridad economía y comercio al tiempo
que reafirmaron los valores democráticos
que unen a estos dos países
y finalizó la Cumbre de la cop 15 que
tuvo lugar en la ciudad de Montreal en
Canadá el encuentro dejó un acuerdo
histórico en materia de biodiversidad
nuestra corresponsal en ese país
Carolina Villa mediana nos cuenta más
la madrugada este lunes se firmó en
Montreal el marco global para la
biodiversidad en el que 196 países se
comprometieron con 23 metas para frenar
el deterioro de los ecosistemas del
planeta de aquí al final de la década el
histórico acuerdo que se logra tras
cuatro años de negociaciones establece
el 30 por 30 la protección del 30% de la
superficie terrestres y acuáticas del
planeta de aquí hasta el año 2030 una
meta que sería equiparable al uno punto
cinco grados del acuerdo de París en
materia de cambio climático este acuerdo
también Establece que se reduzcan los
subsidios dañinos a la naturaleza en
hasta 500 mil millones de dólares al año
y la reducción a la mitad en los
desechos alimentarios y también en los
efectos nocivos de los pesticidas para
financiar estas metas se estableció la
creación de un fondo de 200 mil millones
de dólares al año provenientes de
fuentes públicas privadas nacionales e
internacionales así como también la
creación de un flujo financiero hacia
los países en vías de desarrollo de unos
30 mil millones de dólares al año la
República democrática del Congo no
estuvo de acuerdo con la aprobación de
este marco y reclamó que los recursos
que se le ofrecían a los países en vías
de desarrollo eran insuficientes para lo
ambicioso de las metas sin embargo este
comentario fue tomado como un reclamo
informal y no como una objeción formal
por lo que el acuerdo fue Igualmente
aprobado las ong ambientalistas piden
que los gobiernos comiencen a crear
planes nacionales y que los presenten
antes de la cop16 que se celebrará en
Turquía en 2024 esto en las noticias
siga con nosotros
[Música]